we've so far been looking at probability
density functions pictures are them that
like interesting and unusual right
shapes like this that looked like what
we call the normal distribution which
we'll get to a bit later or weird
wonderful curves that do whatever you
like right but actually one of the most
common situations of is what we call a
uniform distribution which is not a
weird unusual shape it's a very simple
shape what does it mean when we say
something is uniform when students wear
uniforms it's the same right it's the
same so it's not like hey this event is
less likely than this event right we're
trying to imagine a distribution with
every single event has exactly the same
probability the exact uh each outcome
has the same chance
I guess now for that reason if your
probability which is on the vertical
axis right if it's always going to be
the same you get very boring shape out
of this right it's just going to be a
horizontal line of some kind if I
drawing that parallel parallel ish I can
do better than that
I look gonna look at a little more eyes
on there we go okay so you said there's
very simple shape because the
probability all the way along is the
same value okay if we were to put some
boundaries on this let's say for example
we had some event and I don't know it
has the lowest possible value happens to
be 3 the highest possible value is or
now to know what does that look like
something like 17 okay you can tell me
off of those boundaries everything about
this probability density function right
let's have a think about this what is
this distance across the top here it's
14 right 17 take away 3 but because
that's 14 and I know the total
probability equals 1
you've got the width of the rectangle so
you can therefore just work out the
height
what's it equal to 1 over 14 right like
I've got a multiplied by this and get
one do you agree with that a fourteenth
very good ok so we could generalize this
if you have some uniform distribution if
a situation gets given to you like this
one that I'm showing to you on the
screen and it's like and I say to you
hey all the outcomes are equally likely
okay
you see to know what your banners are
yeah yeah this is this is some this is
how probable the event is right yeah so
therefore we can generalize this we can
say if you have some probability density
function that's defined between a and B
and if it's uniform okay what is that f
of X going to be the f of X is going to
be equal to it's it's it's this
horizontal line right it's 1 over how do
we get 14 again
wouldn't it come from it came from this
distance right all difference I should
say 17 take away 3 so that's your
whatever your topic andriy is take away
whatever your bottom boundary is so we
would say top boundary bottom boundary
done that's it um it's simple because
it's a simple shape all right